savez-vous combien coûte un tueur à gage
sur le Dark web beaucoup trop cher
jusqu'à 200000 dollars à ce prix-là
autant le faire soi-même ça c'est des
vrais couteau mais si vous souhaitez
vous en tirer en toute impunité va
falloir prendre des précautions la
police technique et scientifique ne va
pas vous laisser depis quelles sont
leurs méthodes y a-t-il des failles vous
allez découvrir des affaires à vous
faire froid dans le dos comment votre
corps vous trahira les empreunes
digitales c'est la preuve clichée elles
sont uniques à chaque individu même
celles des jumeaux parfaits sont
différentes vous n'avez avec une chance
sur 64 milliards d'avoir les mêmes que
quelqu'un d'autre c'est extrêmement
aléatoire vitesse de croissance de
l'embryon frontement de ses doigts
généti on s'en sert pour signer des
œuvres d'art depuis Babylone et des
contrats en Chine ancienne pour la
première fois en 1892 elles ont été
utilisé au Brésil dans une enquête liée
à un meurtre d'enfant la méthode finit
ensuite par être popularisée grâce au
français Bertillon partout où on nous
pose nos doigts on dépose un mélange de
sueurs sébum et cellules mortes il ne
reste plus qu'à le révéler avec de la
poudre de de la fumée aussi anneau
acrylate de la superglue au contact de
l'humidité la fumée de la superglue va
se solidifier autour des traces comme un
moule on peut alors les comparer à celle
d'un suspect ou à une base de données ça
marche pas toujours ce pauvre retraité
en a fait les frais arrêté à glasgo en
2019 on pensait avoir trouvé du pont de
Ligones recherché depuis presque 10 ans
pour le meurtre de sa famille pas de bol
pour Guy la police écossaise basse sa
comparaison sur CIN points similaires
avec les empreintes du tueur il passe
des heures garde à vue avant que la
police française vérifie parce que chez
nous c'est 12 points qu'il faut et là ça
colle pas il passe quand même par le
test ADN avant d'être relâché la
technique du poudrage date du crime des
enfants au Brésil et a très peu évolué
l'université de lenchester a développé
une nouvelle méthode avec
l'électrochimie et la fluorescence plus
rapide plus précise cette méthode révèle
des empreintes très peu marquées ou sur
des surfaces mouillées ou brûlées
quelques nanomètres de matière suffisent
à l'identification effacer vos tras
devient impossible contrairement à une
idée reçue se brûler le bout des doigts
ne fait pas disparaître totalement vos
empreintes le temps de cicatriser vos
mains seront inutilisables et tout
finira par réapparaître on connaît
quelques cas de personnes qui naissent
sans empreinte mais c'est une maladie
génétique très rare la dermatoglyphie on
ne connaît que quatre familles atteintes
dans le monde par contre ils ont
toujours les lignes de la paume de la
main et ces empreintes la police s'en
servent aussi heureusement vous avez une
solution moins cher plus rapide porte
des gants mais il y a plein d'autres
moyens de vous attraper d'abord votre
carte d'identité biologique votre ADN on
peut tout savoir de vous avec ça sexe
origine couleur des yeux des cheveux de
peau qui sont vos parents et même vos
maladies on pourra bientôt sortir un
portrait robot grâce à ça il suffit d'un
minuscule échantillon et de le comparer
avec la base de données on en laisse
partout tout le temps dans nos cellules
qu'on perd en se frottant quelque part
dans la sueur ou la plus infine trace de
sang même s'il est nettoyer depuis
longtemps on en a retrouvé congelé au
Grenland vieux de plus de 2 millions
d'années il serait difficile à exploiter
mais ils peuvent facilement travailler
sur un ADN vieux de plusieurs dizaines
d'années une des plus vieilles affaires
résolu grâce à ça date de plus de 65 ans
Patricia et Lloyd sont un jeune couple
d'adolescents du Montana retrouvé mort
en 1956 tué d'une balle dans la tête le
jeune homme était ligoté et elle a vécu
l'horreur en 2001 un inspecteur repasse
les indices au cribles et on découvre
sur la jeune femme un spermatozoïde qui
n'appartient pas à son petit ami ça doit
être le meurtrier mais aucun moyen de le
retrouver c'est seulement en 2012 qu'un
enquêteur se Pench sur ce colce et
envoie les preuves au labo l'ADN est
comparée avec la base de données et là
les enquêteurs trouvent une
correspondance un membre de la famille
qui avait fait un test volontaire ils
ont ensuite facilement remonté la piste
pour identifier le tueur et si vous avez
déjà fait un test ADN pour connaître vos
origines vous êtes coincé votre cousin a
fait un test on va vite remonter jusqu'à
vous le bulbe d'un de vos cheveux suffit
alors on se rase la tête contrairement à
l'idée reçue un cheveux tombé ne
contient pas d'ADN il est constitué de
cellules mortes solidifiées comme les
ongles la kératine et si par miracle
vous ne laissez pas ce genre de trace on
peut vous identifier grâce à vos dents
ultra résistant avec une forme unique
choc violent incendie même dans les
pires catastrophes où il ne reste rien
des victimes on les retrouve quasi
intactes la police ne vous retrouvera
pas grâce à ça mais si vous êtes suspect
vous êtes cuit vous connaissez peut-être
pet Bundy dans les années 70 l'Amérique
connaî une série de meurtres et
d'agressions sauvages c'est le suspect
mais on ne trouve rien pour l'accuser
formellement jusqu'à à qu'on se rend
compte qu'une de ses victimes porte des
traces de morsures provenant de dents
ébréché et crochu comme celle de Ted
c'est grâce à la comparaison dentaire
qu'on réussit à l'inculper condamné à
mort pour plus de 30 crimes plus
insolite retenez-vous si vous avez une
envie pressante des étude envisage la
possibilité d'identification fécale oui
oui vous avez bien compris les bactéries
présentes dans notre caca sont
différentes d'une personne à l'autre la
police peut aussi exploiter les éléments
que vous transportez avec vous de lieux
en lieux les poils de votre chaton
peuvent se retrouver sur la scène de
crime la terre ou le pollen sous vos
chaussures peuvent révéler votre
quartier et enfin les odeurs que l'on
dégage chaque personne à la sienne
unique un cocktail de plusieurs
centaines de molécules qui persiste même
des jours après notre passage mélange de
notre sueur des bactéries à la surface
de notre peau et même de nos maladies
avec une éponge organogel micropeureux
les techniciens de la police vont
absorber les odeurs et les passer dans
un appareil qui va identifier chaque
molécule un spectromètre de masse on a
ainsi une signature reconnaissable
archivée et valable devant la justice
cette technique est particulièrement
coûteuse mais une version moins chère et
utilisée depuis plusieurs années en
France grâce à des chiens super
entraînés ils peuvent identifier une
odeur à partir d'un échantillon dans
l'affaire de disparition de Maelis en
2017 les chiens vont comparer l'odeur de
la petite fille avec les odeurs relevées
dans la voiture du suspect numéro 1
nordal lollandais les chiens n'ont pas
pu identifier l'enfant mais leur
comportement a signalé autre chose le
Landais avait nettoyé sa voiture avec
des quantités industrielles de produits
chimiques c'est cet indice qui va
pousser les enquêteurs à étudier le
véhicule à fond pour finir par trouver
une goutte de sang de la petite et pour
ne pas vous faire prendre vous pensez
peut-être à vous équiper d'une tenue
jaune à la Breaking Bad ben ça sera pas
suffisant comment le cadavre de votre
victime va vous dénoncer avez-vous déjà
pensé à donner votre corps à la science
si oui vous pourriez finir ici la ferme
des corps un genre de parc Glo où les
scientifiques laissent pourrir les
cadavres à l'air libre pour étudier les
différentes phases de la putréfaction à
quoi ça sert identifier avec une grande
précision l'heure du décès de la victime
et même le lieu et ça on le sait grâce à
plusieurs choses déjà la température du
corps au moment de la mort vous partez
de 37° puis en fonction de la météo le
cadavre va se refroidir jusqu'à
atteindre la température ambiante à une
vitesse qu'on connaît une fois arrivé là
on a un autre indice de temps qui prend
le relais après le décès les muscles de
la victime vont se contracter puis de
nouveau s'assouplir avec le temps c'est
ce qu'on appelle la rigidité cadavérique
ensuite on peut étudier comment le sang
fiche dans le corps il va se concentrer
dans les parties les plus basses par la
gravité et changer la couleur de la peau
c'est la lividité cadavérique en
examinant les couleurs et l'emplacement
des tâches on peut affiner l'heure de
décès et même si le corps a été déplacé
après la mort pour effacer votre rass et
enfin en étudiant toutes les petites
bestioles sur le corps comme un steak
hors du frigo des insectes nécrophages
vont venir s'installer manger épondre
des œufs en fonction de ce présent et
des stades de développement des larves
on arrive à remonter jusqu'au jour du
décès voir le lieu vous pensez peut-être
supprimer lesépreuves en passant le
corps à la chauud comme dans les films
ça dissou le corps non au contraire ça
va ralentir la décomposition en
réduisant l'humidité et endurcissant les
tissus on a aussi découvert que
contrairement à ce qu'on pensait un
corps obèse se décompose plus vite à
cause de la quantité de chair qui
nourrit les mouches et en examinant les
blessures de la victime on en apprendra
encore plus sur vous déjà on détermine
quasi automatiquement l'arme du crime
forme profondeur largeur la PL en dit
beaucoup si vous êtes droitier ou
gaucher de quel côté vous étiez si vous
êtes grand petit fort ou faible des
blessures de combat ou de simples
griffures peuvent vous relier à la
victime qui s'est défendu et si vous
utilisez un pistolet la balle laissée
donnera toutes les infos nécessaires le
projectile donnera le type de votre arme
et en comparant au microscope l'Estrier
laissé par le canon de l'arme sur la
balle on pourra l'identifier pour éviter
ça vous vous dites peut-être que vous
pourriez détruire les preuve en vous
débarrassant du cadavre déjà les
méthodes sont peu fiables il y a
toujours des bouts qui restent et on l'a
vu ça prend énormément de temps pour
certains le corps se décompose moins
vite qu'avant à cause des conservateurs
présents dans nos aliments outre les
empreintes digitales et l'ADN la police
scientifique dispose d'une multitude de
méthodes d'identification de la victime
la forme et la structure de ses os
permettent d'identifier son sexe et son
âge pour peu que la victime ait déjà
fait une radio des dents une comparaison
permettra de remonter à son identité si
elle a été opérée avec du matériel
chirurgical chaque broche vis ou un plan
comporte un numéro d'identification
unique un tatouage une Tâage de
naissance ou n'importe quel autre détail
pourra aider à l'identification et il
reste encore aux enquêteurs une source
d'information que vous ne pourrez pas
dissimulé comment la scène de crime va
vous identifier les scènes de crime sont
rarement propres et très souvent avec
des traces de sang celui de la victime
comme le vôre allant tapisser les murs
le sol et même le plafond de notre point
de vue un cauchemar à nettoyer trop
relou en plus j'ai exposé mon forc
mobile pour les enquêteurs un livre
ouvert sur ce qui s'est passé en
étudiant les formes les tailles les
angles et et le placement des gouttes de
sang on appelle cette méthode la
morphoanalyse des traces de sang par
exemple des taches allongées peuvent
indiquer la trajectoire du couteau après
avoir blessé la victime une tachche en
forme d'étoile indiquera les restes d'un
coup de feu un blanc sur une traînée de
sang indiquera un obstacle était présent
sur la trajectoire de jiclé vous
peut-être alors vous vous dites que vous
allez tout nettoyer à grand saut javel
c'est pas gagné les microogoutelettes
vont s'infiltrer dans le moindre creux
rendant un nettoyage totalement
impossible en vaporisant le fameux
luminol on va va révéler les plus
infines traces qu'il reste alors ce
n'est pas comme dans les séries où on
voit les gouttes de sambrier comme un
t-shirt blanc en boîte de nuit le
luminul contient un agent oxydant qui va
réagir avec le fer présent dans
l'hémoglobine c'est cette réaction qui
va provoquer une lumière bleue ou verte
la chimie luminescence le luminol réagit
aussi à la javelle donc la police voyant
une zone entièrement lumineuse va faire
comme dans l'affaire l'olandais chercher
plus loin et si vous n'êtes pas arme de
contact utiliser une arme à feu laissera
tout autant de traces si ce n'est plus
déjà une fois que vous auurez tiré des
résidus de poudre se déposent sur vos
mains et vos vêtements facilement
détectables sous lumière infrarouge car
les molécules qui les composent
absorbent cette lumière et paraîtront
sombres sur un support clair à partir
d'un impact de balle de la géométrie
relativement simple et des lasers vont
déterminer votre position de tir exact
si vous étiez en mouvement si vous êtes
petit ou grand les techniciens vont
faire une vraie reconstitution de la
scène aujourd'hui ils sont équipés
d'outils comme les laser scanners la
cartographie numérisée en 3D
photoréaliste d'une scène de crime va
prendre quelques quel minutes au lieu de
plusieurs semaines même les autopsies
sont faites grâce à des robots sans même
inciser la peau maintenant comment vous
rendre sur les lieux en voiture pour
amener votre matos mauvaise idée rien
que les marques de vos pneus vont servir
à identifier le type de véhicule SUV
sportif petite citadine ou camionnette
elles ont toutes leurs spécificités il y
a juste à comparer une photo ou un
moulage des empreintes avec la base de
données si vous avez emporté votre
téléphone portable c'est mort entre le
GPS les journaux d'appel ce que vous
postez sur les réseaux toute votre vie
est publicque même en supprimant les les
données ou en les détruisant ils
arrivent toujours à récupérer des
informations en transport en commun ou
même à pied il y a des caméras partout
permettant de vous traquer les feux de
signalisation les distributeurs ou même
les sonnettes connectées des voisins
vous filment en permanence
officiellement la reconnaissance faciale
n'est pas pratiquée par la police en
France en dehors des enquêtes pour
meurtrre ou disparition mais toutes les
technologies sont là les données
biométriques le fichier qui les traite
et les applications de comparaison et en
expérimentation depuis 2019 dans
certains aéroports et gar la Chine est
d'ailleurs précurseur dans le domaine
pour les cont contrôle aux frontières
par exemple grâce à une entreprise
française la science de la
criminalistique est basée sur le
principe que chaque contact laisse des
traces cette phrase date des années 1900
et avec les nouvelles technologies les
traces sont de plus en plus nombreuses
impossibl à tout effacer la seule
difficulté c'est de bien les récolter et
là on tombe sur le caillou dans la
godasse de Sherlock Holmes le facteur
humain anid Duan est une chimiste de la
police scientifique de Boston très
productive en moins de 10 ans elle a
traité plus de 60000 échantillons grâce
à ses analyses 1141 personnes sont sous
les des roues le problème elle a avoué
avoir baacé son travail parfois en
rendant des résultats au pif de test
qu'elle n'avait même pas fait son
explication trop de boulot la solution
peut-on prédire les crimes plus besoin
d'enquêter plus besoin de preuve en 1876
on étudiait les têtes coupées des
criminels pour trouver des
caractéristiques communes qu'on pourrait
ensuite chercher chez les gens c'est la
craniologie de l'ombreoso si vous avez
un petit crâne deux grandes orbites ou
encore des bras plus longs que la
normale des dents mal foutu ou des
doigts en trop vous êtes un futur
criminelle on va même plus loin en
créant des portraits robots de criminel
par exemple ceci ça vous rappelle
quelqu'un comme si le crime était
inscrit dans nos gèes et pouvait se voir
sur nous bon ces stéréotypes
pseudoscientifiques partent vite à la
poubelle et on n'a pas réussi à trouver
de prégogs à la Minority Report ou
peut-être que si avec les mathématiques
et une équation inspirée des
tremblements de terre elle montre que
comme lors d'un tremblement de terre il
y a des répliques après une secousse les
crimes ont une tendance à suivre les
mêmes schémas la survenue d'un meurtre
dans une zone augmente le risque d'en
avoir un autre tout proche dans les
jours qui suivent et c'est comme ça
qu'une carte météo du crime pourrait
voir le jour une équipe de l'université
de Chicago a fini le modèle spécifique
dans sa ville avec une précision de
prédiction de 90 % une semaine à
l'avance on a quand même un gros souci
de renforcement de Bill avec ses
méthodes on identifie une zone à risque
de crime dans un quartier sensible on
envoie alors des policiers qui vont
trouver un truc du coup on envoie plus
de policiers qui vont trouver plus de
trucs et cetera et cetera une autre
méthode en cours d'étude et l'analyse
comportementale automatisé les profilers
vous connaissez sûrement ces gens qui
savent interpréter le comportement d'une
personne et quasi deviner leur action
imaginez un programme qui serait
entraîné à détecter les comportements
suspects sur les réseaux sociaux ou sur
les caméras de surveillance et qui
signalerait les personnes qui
s'apprêtent à passer à l'acte il
suffirait d'isoler ce suspect pour le
stopper et l'empêcher de provoquer des
répliques ce serait un peu comme arrêter
la propagation d'une épidémie mais de
crime c'est même une science
l'épidémiologie criminelle ça fait un
peu black mirir non mais c'est déjà
notre réalité il existe un algorithme
États-Unis utilisé pour prédire qui sera
déjà victime de violence armée à
l'avenir alors désolé cette vidéo ne
pourra pas vous apprendre à faire le
crime parfait parce que vous êtes
presque sûr de vous faire prendre on
vous aura peut-être évité de finir en
prison si c'était votre projet merci de
laisser un like et de vous abonner à la
chaîne on se retrouve très vite pour une
prochaine
[Musique]
vidéo